[Music]
Gomez: Wallapop is a simple application.
It is a market for used goods
On your mobile phone where each item is located
Simulates the Wallapop application on your mobile device
Shopping in neighborhoods
Where you can browse the goods
Sold by your neighbors.
Purchase of goods on the application is similar to traditional purchases from stores.
It differs greatly from the purchase of the usual classified goods.
I realized at a stage of my life
The time is ripe for a new challenge.
I decided to start working on the Wallapop application in Barcelona.
On the first day we were only two people
And one month after the application was created
We achieved first place
In Spain on the Play Store.
One of the main features of the Wallapop application is its simplicity.
People aged 15 to 60 were selling goods
On the Wallapop website.
More than 70% of our application users
From Android platform owners.
Joey: My name is Marta and I work for Wallapop
As Director of Growth and Marketing.
We started a year ago using store data experiments
After the testing phase, downloads improved without any incentives by 17%.
We first started testing
Many factors at the same time
We have not reached the desired result
We decided to test each element individually.
We decided to start testing the brief description.
As a result, downloads improved without any incentives of 6%.
Then we ran another test with the Business Information Analysis team
Who told us about best-selling applications.
We conducted four different experiments
With four distinct products
To test the extent to which users are attracted to it
During the tests, we found out
There are two types of users
Users who have already decided to download the app and experienced users.
So we created an easily recognizable envelope
By users who have previously decided to download the application
Using the main logo of the Wallapop application
And what was displayed in the app's ad on your TV.
We also tried changing the order of screens
To see how this affects the app download rate
We have achieved excellent results.
When creating your Google Play store page
Consider the first impression factor
Because it may be the only opportunity available to you
To convince the user to download your app.
Gomez: Since the launch of the Wallapop application
We expanded and became a big family.
We have had a great success
Happens once in a lifetime
I am very grateful for my success at
Lead this team. This was the most difficult experience
And the greatest in my life.